and I mean maybe then I
drove over the Alps and I was
35 at the time and I thought to myself, well, man, of
course, I can still
do ten or 20 years with me, they will stay,
but then I will always only stand on the
sidelines and always  I only
advise people on how to implement something and
here I have the opportunity to work on the
technology that
can change humanity, which
can really also secure Germany as a business location and uh you're
not just so clear you have a
bit of this risk but like that
I think I have a permanent job here, you
know, and I'm going to
a startup here, um, in the deepack area, which
somehow wasn't clear at the time,
but where it's
going, but then I thought to myself,
sometimes I can't say at 35
I'm so risky now, but only since
I no longer dare to do something new
and then I came back from the
bike tour on Sunday evening,
went to Marvel Fusion on Monday and said I'm
doing it as a guest today, a lady who is
about herself  says she is an
insecure over Ed Sheeran at 35 which I
already see as a partner with me today is
responsible for Marvel Fusion a
deep check company from Germany
that would like to solve our energy problems in the next few years
so that it
would certainly become a multiple unicorn let's go  Welcome to the
conversation with Heike
Freund Heike Freund Heike hey hello
Philipp I'm very happy to be here,
briefly tell me in a few words the company
you represent is called Marvel Fusion
what do you do at Marvel Fusion we are working
on a completely new approach to
nuclear fusion  to commercialize on earth
fusion processes these are the processes
that take place in the sun every day and
generate energy there and we want to
bring the sun down to earth and
produce energy here with fusion processes
this is a CO2-free, safe, clean
energy source and that is exactly what it is
what we still need in the energy mix is ​​added
so you can say since
sustainability from yes definitely so
I mean CO2 free clean safe
energy source is exactly what we
need and maybe also to
transport that so nuclear fusion is
exactly the opposite  nuclear fission,
so we fuse atomic nuclei
together and that means
we have no long-lived radioactive
waste, no risk of chain reactions and it
is a CO2-free source of energy, so it
is not wind or sun or
something that you can grasp and
understand immediately, it is also
a physical one  highly complex process
all probably one of the
most complicated physics problems to be
solved in this century how
we can harness the fusion energy on earth
but if we
can harness it the potential is
gigantic because uh well i have to
imagine i could with  a
fusion power plant produce a gigawatt on the
area of ​​the football field
so a gIGA was that produces as much electricity as a
large coal-fired power plant
and I could do that right
next to the big cities
I could do that right next to
the chemical plant next to the mountain and stuff
like that  further so very precisely the
energy source that we also need above all
here in Germany as a business location
I read a few articles about it
in advance and it said then
I have to be
honest I have little
idea about the content of course but then you could read this
solution is  about 20 years
away it has already been said,
however, it has even been said for 60 years
that somehow they
want to solve this problem in the yes,
insofar as it doesn't seem to
be that easy and what makes you sure
that's coming now, I think  The good thing
is we currently have a huge
momentum infusion market and there are
gigantic scientific
advances last December,
so just three months ago
science in the USA succeeded for the first
time in using fusion processes
to generate more energy than was put in,
so energy was generated
through laser-based fusion that was a
huge milestone in December 2022 that's
super super great on the other hand
we use lasers in our technology
to make that possible, there was a
Nobel Prize in Physics in 2018 that has exactly the
technology that you
need now, so huge scientific ones
Progress and that is now also
seen by investors because last year
I think a total of 4.8 billion flowed
into private function campaigns that
is more than the total flowed into the last 20 years before that
so
investors have recognized it
scientific breakthroughs and I
think so too  the need for
additional energy sources has never been as great
as it is now, and from that point of view I am totally
optimistic that we will
see fusion power plants in the next ten years
if you are the person
in your team who also scientifically
penetrates it and
makes it scientifically possible, so to speak, so the
the  internally or or are you the
manager so we are
CEO and CEO in our management team I am CEO
and then the scientific
responsibility does not lie with our CTO
Georg Korn who has been
active in this area for over 40 years is the
most powerful laser systems in the world
and also played a
key role in this Nobel Prize, which was awarded in 2018.
Warensträger himself, the
Nobel Prize winner,
is today Gerard, so that’s what
we need in this advisory
role, he’s now over 80
and Georg Korn, our CTO, was his
most important employee
researching the Nobel Prize
georg yes he is already 70 okay
but still retired
but is with us every day but you i
also find this topic how do
you manage so with diversity you
always talk about all possible dimensions
i  find a dimension that is totally under-
noticed, this topic is also how do
I get quasi-
experienced knowledge holders to be successful
together with young people in a team
and I think we do that
very well here, so we have
scientists who come directly from the
university with one  with a
doctor’s degree and combine them
with very, very experienced
laser scientists physicists so
things again on their own so I
understand lasers play a big role
and somehow energy has to be transmitted via
lasers exactly so maybe we’ll go back
into the processes a little bit
yes we’ll shoot at small ones
Fuel pellets with lasers and
through the lasers we deposit energy
into the fuel pellets and
thus trigger the fusion reactions
and that then releases so much energy
when you can then use it as electricity as everything
exactly so the end product of this
fusion product process is heat and
positively charged particles  positively
charged particles can be
converted into electricity via induction and heat
can be converted into electricity via normal steam turbines
and when do you think that
it will work so far that
you can really supply a
company or a village or even a
city with it, i.e. me  I would
like to build commercial power plants in 10 years
I know that this is totally
ambitious and um that there
is still a lot to do to make it necessary, but
we already have a few
strong industrial partners on board, so
that is exactly what we want to develop together with the entire power plant
technology  with
Siemens Energy I am convinced
that as a small company, we are 70
people, you cannot
develop everything yourself in-house, that means
we do that together
with Siemens Energy and are already developing
the power plant technology
and from  So I'm convinced that
we can do it in 10 years,
but it still needs
more support, more money,
government support, okay, so in
ten years it's already incredibly long for start-up cycles,
so it's
very unusual for someone to be so long
think about it yes and no, well I
think with deep tech topics it's already
a normal timeline and so
infusion area that's probably
the most ambitious timeline you
can imagine and if it
works then you're in the company
a bit like that  let me say how
as RWE or or or Vattenfall or
or somehow in the end sells energy
we would already produce energy
so erm see
Marvel exactly and then we can he's
called yes there I would then that
could be a partnership with
one of the big ones  do it together
like you do with the vaccine, you have
also seen that in
partnerships with us it
rolled out on a large scale in the end, uh, exactly, and the
costs that are to be generated will then
also be lower in ten years,
at least in perspective, than we say now with electricity
from the sun  or from wind, so for me
the goal is very clear that it
has to be competitive with wind water and
solar and from that point of view the price has to be
under 5 cents per kilowatt hour
and I'm also convinced that
we can do it, yes, but this
effort rings a bell  yes big
why I think if sun and wind
were to solve the problem then it's
actually enough you wind water and solar
will unfortunately not
cover the total electricity requirements of the earth so the
electricity requirements no matter which study you
look at by 2050 will
either double or  triple
or quadruple
or so exactly so complete
decaronization of the industry
maybe a number that I found
my pling um from the study for
German chemical society or
something once calculated if I want to decaronize the
entire chemical industry in Germany
I need 628
hours
of electricity  Today's electricity consumption in
Germany is, I think, 580
terawatt hours, so I need more
electricity just to decarbonize the chemical industry
than
Germany's current electricity demand is, and that
it's not just the chemical industry, that's
aluminum steel, concrete, all the
energy-rich industries, then there's the
decarbonization of traffic  through
electric vehicles electric heat pumps
in the houses and and and and and
so all in all we will need much more
electricity in the future at least
double maybe is triple and
I will not be able to solve that with wind water and solar
alone and above all
I will be here in  Germany as a
business location cannot be
solved at competitive prices because
here in Germany wind, water
and solar will always be more expensive than in
other regions of the world, which means that the
danger we run into is that Germany as a
business location is industrialized as a whole
that we are no longer here  can have
industry at competitive prices
and that is the backbone
for our prosperity peace and so
on
okay but that means you have
clear eyes on the target price because it
is already recognizable where the target price
will be in the other areas in the
future and then you know what you can
achieve  what can you keep up with
exactly so I think you could always
ask for a certain premium for being
able to generate electricity in a small space and also 24 hours a day
because that is the second disadvantage of the
renewables that they sun and only
when  the sun is shining and then
when the wind is blowing and so on,
you will probably be able to ask for a certain premium,
but I am going by the
market price first and then in ten
years you will not make any sales either,
so maybe there will be something right away
we'll look at it, I also mean
this laser technology that we're
developing, it's cutting-
edge science and it also has
other areas of application, for example
in the field of medical technology,
cancer therapy,
material sciences and so on, that
means you can always
look at it there, maybe  so to speak, there are
early revenue generation streams
because I can
perhaps already use or license technologies that we are developing here in
other fields,
but that, um, exactly from
this pure merger area,
you will only then generate the sales,
but that's the way it is, I
always compare it a bit  so the
value of what we do is perhaps
more comparable to an oil field,
even if that's exactly the
difference, because when the oil falls, it's
also the second I discovered the oil
falling and see that I'm getting
oil from this oil field  I can promote
the value of the oil field and not
only when I have got the last drop of oil out of
the oil field
what are the films worth today, so to speak,
I think our evaluation is
not public at all, but so far we have
60 million in private
capital  ok so also from
big investors so early bird that
was from the time here in the podcast
also actually from classic
vissees
for example in early bird but
also blue yes prime piles and then
we also have family offices and
single individuals like  an Albert Wenger
Tobi lötke tavita
shopify founder but also fast
podcast by Julian squareventures
who is still so
big exactly then um who next to the
responsibility computing at Google
who do we still have Athos
[music]
I've always learned that way or
now also deal with it from time to time
lastly with the topic and then
everyone always say so the accolade as an
investor in this
sustainability area is
breaks ventures that he is in the shape of
Bill Gates that's like that that's like that
that's the absolute super
single address I wouldn't even go for
definitely say yes, because break free
energy and uh, Bill Gates per se
believes very strongly in these small
modular reactors, the new form
of nuclear fission, and I don't believe
in it because these new
reactors are safer but
still produce  long-lived
radioactive waste and from the
stove are not the solution for the future for me,
so this new generation of
nuclear fission reactors and Bill Gates is betting
very heavily on it with the
cloud reactors that he is developing
I'm
convinced that fusion
energy is an important energy source in the
future of energiemixer, but maybe
I mean I'm totally happy that
we have people with
investors like Albert Wenger
who also support deep tech topics
here in Germany and I
would be super happy if it would  they give a lot more
early birds because I
think we are already something so
capital-intensive that day that's
not let me say that in which every
investor can now invest super easily and quickly
and has early bird,
for example  also invested in Isa Aerospace, so
they have already
gone a bit far in this area, supporting the Pack here in
Germany Europe,
fundraising is very difficult, so
you spoke to many WC, many
said it was too long for us
or  or I think you have a
special group of investors who
can do something like that, yes, the day is
capital-intensive and not easy
to grasp as a topic, so sometimes you need
a lot of knowledge to
be able to assess a topic like this and you
have to be honest about it  the 4.8
billion I mentioned earlier
that was invested in sums in the last ten years,
no sorry,
in private
companies 90 percent of it was invested in fusion energy in the USA
and choose what they choose
for their classic  Toilets yes, but you also
have a tiger globally and
similar, so
it becomes
very clear as a business, so
you can only do that in the
last year, I would
say, through the scientific
breakthroughs through the technological
breakthroughs, so the last 18 to 24
Months ago I'd say this great
momentum in the market and how much money do you
think you need in the end, in total it
's already 60 million so far what do
you think at the end of the 10
years or are you always starting with
sales what do you think brown?  In addition to the 60
million, we got money
from the agency at the beginning of March
to
develop our laser technology,
exactly
in addition, we now have 90 million at the beginning of
March, so the agency for the jump situation will have a
total of 90 million, half of which will be
available to us  to
develop our laser technology,
that means that comes next, then the
next step for us is
to build our own technology demonstrator, which
will then cost a total of 200 million,
which we still have to dig and then
the first power plants after that, that's what
you're talking about  of the billion plus but
I would love to
put that together with a potential customer okay but the big
important next step is really
possibly technology demonstrator for that
was now the one from the agency for jump
innovation in the first important step
yes okay so that  but that means in total
the money is over 100 and we're
then talking about another 200 kilos, you
need to
try to find it, so I think that
's a company like ours will
always be primarily privately financed,
of course we're also talking about a
wide variety of funding pots and  see
what's still possible, but as if paying,
I'd say about two-thirds will
always be private capital, also
much faster
if someone is listening and happens to be two
million,
so you're really looking for it now,
as if in doubt, it's also
about wealthy private individuals  maybe
because the otto family or someone who
can afford it
as we are talking to all the big family
offices as they are increasing now
also industry the
classic owl gas players we
also have to see how they
can diversify in the future
speak clearly and  How does a
young woman like you get into this world,
I mean if you look at LinkedIn
you studied something, erm,
engineering and by then
I think I ended up having children after a few internships
and then I
see it was very successful with my child
you can read about it so
in the end it was a partner for 10 years that's
a hard needle to say
so being a middle partner is really
the big school of what
you can tear off in the business administration area
what did you succeed with  Well, I
think I came to Fusion a
bit like a virgin
because, as you rightly said,
I first
studied industrial engineering in Karlsruhe and then I actually
always had a fascination for technology
and always wanted to understand how
things work  I also did a lot of
internships back then in Formula 1
in the car industry, but I did
n’t want to go directly into the
car industry but
thought, man, to look a bit more
broadly at what’s out there and then I
actually went to me by accident she came to me back
then  somehow at such
an event skiing Kitzbühel Alps
and so on such a classic
recruiting student event the
people all found it totally exciting
got to know you there and then
thought man that sounds really
exciting when they went to macin then thought
I'd do it  somehow
for two years and was there for 10 years at the end
and I thought it was super great for
me, you know, so it was super
exciting I did projects
from somehow in
China in Pakistan in Brazil in the USA
but not always energy not at all  I did
a lot of auto industry back then,
mechanical engineering, did high-tech industry,
but always on the but always so
operations topics so a lot so
productions purchasing development where I
feel very comfortable as an engineer
I would say in the area and always
a lot at this interface how do
you get it  big ideas from
development into reality so that was
mine, so to speak, at mckinse over
time you also specialize in
a few topics and that was my
topic and then in 2020 I had just
finished the first Corona lockdown
and then  where you
could have lunch with friends again and
I was having lunch with friends
and Moritz the CEO of Marvel Fusion is sitting next to me
and tells me that was
May 2020, yes he just
founded a company here in Munich for fusions
energy and with fusions energy  can you
produce CO2-free, clean, safe electricity
Lunch with friends
I take him he tells me about it and
since I’m very interested in people because
in 2020 I already knew from
discussions with all my
McKinsey industrial clients how endangered
Germany is as a business location and
that  we are completely hitting the wall here
with our that we do not
have enough affordable green electricity
that everyone can discuss it we are
still investing at all here
in Germany we have to
shut down our production facilities,
a discussion that I
had already heard very actively in 2020 and then someone sits down
at lunch next to me who
tells me to people with fusion
we could solve exactly this problem I found it
really exciting um I went to
visit fusion afterwards there were
a handful of people who were there at the time but
with the goal of really being the leading
scientists plasma scientists
physicists engineers  to move in together in Munich
and implement this concept
and so I got
into conversation with them for a few weeks and then
Moritz said to me, Heike, I need
you in my team, you are exactly the
piece of the puzzle that I still have in
my team here at the moment  I don't have the
leading scientists Moritz himself
is a
series founder and preneur, but he
still needs this
operational execution excellence, so to speak, which I
might
have learned a bit from quirks, yes, and I was a
Moritz too crazy I'm here what I
said earlier in the partner
you definitely have a
bit of something to go with me yeah um
I thought that um no you’re crazy
and then there was Corona I wanted
or this Corona summer 2020 I
actually wanted to fly to my brother who
lives in California somehow in the summer
then  It wasn't all because of
Corona and so on, so I
rode my racing bike across the Alps as a
summer vacation and then Moritz said
to me before that Heike Mensch on your
racing bike, think about what
videos you could introduce yourself to so that
you come to me yes  and uh i want to
have you on the team and you need
exactly the particle what i still
need here and then i
did my literature about the alps no
together with my friend at that time
and i mean back then i drove myself across the
alps  and I was 35 at the time and I
thought to myself, well, man, of course, I
can stay with Macken for ten or 20 years,
but I'll
always just stand on the sidelines
and always just advise people on how to
implement something and have them  I have the
opportunity to work on the technology
that
can change humanity, which
can really also secure Germany as a business location and you're
not just so clear you have a
bit of this risk, but
I think I kind of have a permanent job here with
me you go and  I'm going to a
start-up in the deepack area where he
somehow wasn't clear at all at the time but
where it's
going but then I thought to myself
man you can't say at 35 I'm
so risky now but only since I did
n't think about it anymore  to do something new and
then I came back from the bike tour came back on
Sunday evening and
went on Monday um and said I
'll do it okay and in a month later you
're also be
whatever is substantial already
a few percent have to belong yes
exactly and me  I mean we
just let it slide a bit
or I think you deliberately
let it slide I still
always want to try to understand if more than
60 million are invested or then again
this financing that is
imminent so you can
assume this  Company is now, at least
on paper, already several 100
million values ​​that has not only
already flowed in but also
tends to think one of the
next then also perspective Unicorn
in Germany absolutely
not yet but could be in the next
financing maybe at  the
next one or the one after that,
but that's absolutely
possible, and I mean the potential
is of course simply gigantic,
because it could actually
solve the energy problem, and if you
solve the energy problem, you'll solve
one of the biggest levers in the
climate crisis  so because I suddenly
have the opportunity to generate CO2-free electricity
I could even
have direct capture again to extract CO2 from the
atmosphere if I
have cheap, affordable green electricity, so the
impact I can generate with it is
huge, so I have to say that  how much did
you understand about the business or
the content, i mean,
you decide to make a
relatively drastic career
change, uh,
you rely on the
engineers who say man corner in ten
years it will work or did you say
no  so typically really really
I'll go in myself I have to
understand for myself what's going on here challenge do you
even know that so of course I've talked to a lot of people
and I've already seen okay
Laser technology is probably one of
the key technologies of this
decade this year I've also
seen okay  what has developed in
laser technologies and so on,
then looked, okay, what
would you need to do fusion with it,
okay, that's
basically conceivable to get there and
talk to a lot of people in the field and then
just had a sum  had a very good gut feeling
also had a very good gut
feeling about the team, so that’s why I say
gut feeling because I
think you can do it for years,
especially at that point in time
in 2020, you would never have
a clear YES or a clear no
and at some point you also have to
say no, I'm jumping now, I'm
kind of getting out of my comfort zone,
so to speak, because what I
have to be told what I was asked at the beginning,
am I responsible for physics,
no Georg Korn, ours looks like
responsible for physics here  as you oh
oh i'm responsible for the topic of
company development for all the
industrial partnerships that we
also have many of these public
policy contacts that we maintain to
simply make this topic of mergers more
prominent in Germany and
those are all topics that i found so
exciting  and I was so keen on it and
I have to say I've been doing it
for two years now, learned an incredible amount
in two years and tell me
Moritz von Linde, the CEO, is he a
physicist or the target or
demonstrated
360ccx, so he did it  actually always
when there were such disruptive technologies,
but not in the physics area either,
but that’s all
financial instruments before that,
but he actually came just like
me, um, like the virgin to the child and
so to speak we have this
mechanic in the team
Scientists in the team and I
made the film for the execution,
for example 360t, that was all in the
fintech area, man, that's
okay
as a
bonus on top of what was
really funny when he
left his last company  he
from plutat I know
Americans also left in Germany
earlier and
they in turn had considered
investing in the merger company and
then commissioned
Moritz for the whole conversion side in the diligence process,
who
had just left his previous company and stuff like that
always a bit for fun as well as
supported, so he has
looked at the conversion since then, so to speak, and
another physicist has
looked at the physics side of actually
another company that
wanted to invest and came back from the process and
said man somehow fusion
super exciting laser fusion super
exciting but the company you were
looking at, dear Julia,
probably won't have it because it
somehow has the following 15 things and
the following 15 weak points and then
Jason and said okay you
seem to have a super planned  Plan
what actually means do
n't you want to set up this company, so
Moritz came along and describe a
bit the general global
map in this merger area, so
in the USA there are quite a few others,
so in total there are about 35 in the private
functional area  up to 40
private fusion campaigns
very different countries and
above all different technologies
so you have to say two thirds
of these
almost 40 global fusion companies
work in the magnetic field so there is
also another technology where
I try to trigger the fusion with the strong magnetic fields at very
high temperatures
other technology there is also
a state project ita means that
in the south of France that is relatively well
known here also
in the media from time to time let me put it that way
that one of the one technology path
two thirds of the companies are doing
is a very new technology
laser technology, which we are
also promoting at Fusion and there is about
a third of the companies and because you have
now also asked about the global map,
of the almost 40
companies, more than two thirds are in the USA
and here in Europe there are a handful
and with  our 60 million
but we are the best found in the EU
and also probably technologically so
mine is now at a milestone
then most
advanced but you know each other so
the American players you know the
French players
so I mean I think there
were 35 of them last year  came three-fourths so there
are now probably 38 39 companies
that can still be listed by name
I think fewer than ten of them have
also received over 50 million in funding
and we are also adding to that so we
are already the best found in the EU anyway
and  also globally there are
fewer than ten who have received more than 50 million
funding now
we are talking two days after
the
nuclear phase-out was finally celebrated in Germany at the weekend,
that was good news for you
I think the nuclear phase-out has
many different facets and  I
also found it very exciting over the weekend
how differently the
international and
national media reported about it,
but I think I'll
come back to the nuclear phase-out, I do
n't think that nuclear fission is a
source of energy, that is, a long-term
source of energy, simply because of
the security risk it has because of
that  long-lived radioactive waste that is
produced and simply because it
is not commercially attractive either, so the
price is simply too high from
classic atomic fission yes, from that point of
view I don’t see
atomic fission playing an important role in the
energy mix in the long term, but
we were now  currently in the
special situation because we
have a bit of a double crisis from
the energy crisis and climate change and now
in the current situation to
decide to take these three nuclear power plants
off the grid, which
have still produced 33 terawatt hours of electricity
and that for the time being also through
coal
In Germany, 1.3 million tons of additional coal are now burned per year.
Somehow written down on the kitchen table
for you. Yes, I
actually looked at it a bit with my colleague yesterday,
so it
's really really exciting when you
think about it together  An additional 1.3 million tons of coal
that are now burned each year
to generate electricity,
and that's why I thought
it was already questionable
to get out of nuclear fission in the situation where we were at the moment, but
in the long term it was definitely the
right one  Decision only based on the
current situation, I think you could have let
it run a few years longer,
maybe a
different number even if
you like paying, yes we had to have a
look at those 33
hours of terror that are still being produced by the three
nuclear power plants
If you look at the 1,500
installed
wind turbines in Germany, they produce a
total of 25 terawatt hours, so it’s
not as if I
could simply compensate for that quickly when I
would have to build more than double the number of wind turbines,
so basically
two more of
these nuclear power plants  simply not for
safety reasons TÜV which but only
plays its role should not have continued
or or certainly I
think it would have been possible
to extend it by one or two years
so in the long term it was definitely the
right decision but that in
quotation marks a bit more what I
of radioactive waste would have been produced, you would
have to
worry about what to do with the
radioactive waste anyway, because of that in
the special situation we
were in now with the energy crisis and climate change,
then to decide to
switch off functioning, safe nuclear power plants and convert them into electricity using lignite
to replace and thus
generate millions of tons of additional CO2 I found that
questionable but
perhaps as a final point
that shows once again the need
to simply have more CO2-free energy sources and with fusions we will be
exactly the energy source
now I have the feeling that you
are of course already deeply involved professionally,
so to speak, of course, of course, you are
now quite well trained in general, economically and socially,
through the whole if
you have a fresh young look at the
world, what is then, so to speak, now
what does the mixture result in  then for a
look so it's more of a positive
look for you say okay uh there should be a
few years and now a
few tons of CO2 have to be added and so
but all in all you will be able to master this climate
change and you will be
able to solve it somehow  or do you say it
's kind of a last shot
that we're also going to send and I'm
happy to fight with you, of course you're also happy to write
with an
interest in economics, of course,
but how optimistic, in the summer
I'm optimistic and I'm
optimistic because we have great
scientists  and we have so
I think there's huge potential in
technology I'm I'm a huge believer in
technology and I believe that
technology is going to show us the way forward
and that with technology we're going to
get these issues under control, which is a
thing that I'm more um yeah  time and again
it causes us to ponder and doubt
the attitude that we
often have here in Germany on new topics to
detect topics where you often do, I would
wish that you would
simply
support and promote new technologies much more strongly and
not always like that  looking for a number of soup
but also just approach it with this
positive mindset and says like that
man there is a technology that
has the potential to really change the world
and that's where we
want to go and
explore that okay um but you say am
End with all your
calculations, always do it on the
kitchen table like that, it will
somehow work with the
because sometimes I have the
feeling that people say yes, I
will solve the technology. There is
no other solution, and there
is one  a bit of an argument
to maybe just be
able to fly on vacation and not
have to worry so much
about the future today but that's
not for you now no figs always
through I want to
enjoy my vacation a bit now  enjoy my life
well, I
honestly think everyone can of course
make a lot of good decisions in their own lifestyle, yes, and so
I'll tell myself very clearly
whether it's nutrition or
transport or something similar, but of course
you can too  must realize
is we in Germany are one percent
of the world population I believe 1.8
percent of global emissions the
biggest contribution we can have in the world
is to develop globally scalable
technology here in Germany
podcast a few weeks ago
so argued with which of course you
always say  I have to when I hear that, or
at least I want to introduce it as a thought,
that
of course it's not at all an
easy thought to say we
only have one percent and that's why we supply
the technology and otherwise
always do one thing and don't neglect the other,
well, that's me  I think
we should all use the levers that each
individual has, whether it's in transport, whether it's
somehow in nutrition and
so on, of course, do everything that
saves CO2 emissions, yes,
we should also, it's
sometimes used as an argument to
say  Man, at some point there will be
fusion and so on and then
we may no longer have to
expand renewables by no means
yes, of course we now have to
push ahead with the expansion of windwater and solar, but as I
said before, the demand for electricity will
double in the world  there will
be enough space for a lot of technologies and I think if
we come to a point at some point where we
say man now we have too much
CO2-free clean safe electricity then
I would know so many great things that we
can still do as we had
before  above you came capture
talked about that I could do then
I can put more water in the salt and do it in
places where I might not
have enough drinking water so if I
had a dense so with little space requirement energy source and so
on so I can do such great things
you can also see the
fact of that somehow in the book because as always
numbers or the world is very much
explained in terms of facts and surprised so
you can recommend ne you can totally
recommend and there it is also shown how
mankind actually with so
which  Dimension you always
take as an indicator for the development of
mankind, which is always scaled very linearly
with the availability
of energy, starting with the fire that
people had at some point up to
atomic fission as the last big big
technological step and that
now has to go on to Sequent  to
be continued to the core no fusion where does
the name Marvel come from it is from
this comic so according to the motto you
need a miracle and that’s why Marvel
or Marvel then more of
marvelous because it would be something really
wonderful if we started fusion  in the world
and I really like the name
Marvel Fusion is just it would be
something great wonderful if we
could master fusion technology on earth so like I said
the research thought I thought someone
landed at least one good bullet from my point of view yes thank you so I um
yes yes right
at the beginning, so to speak,
thank you for the name and then
after that it was never
touched again because
I think the name is great I'm great
and that's actually Marvel is yes if
we because as I said I mean
the sun is powered by fusion processes
so we see every day
when there is blue sky that fusion
can work and so we could say
nature's choice how to produce energy yes
and now we have to stop this shape of the
sun
was clear I mean the solar energy
tries to collect the sun's energy
then on the world and we
say man let's bring the sun in
a bottle to earth
so for non-physicists that just sounds
really very ambitious very
crazy
but it seems I put too
much money into my tiles and so many people are looking
at it so not enough money yet  So
I think that we definitely
need
a lot more money to go into such detect
topics here in Germany in Europe
because there's a real danger that
we'll lose touch with the USA,
as I said in the USA  90% large
capital invested in the USA in
the USA I mentioned earlier, but
this scientific breakthrough
happened at the Lorenz livermond Lab in early
December last year, after which
they again massively ramped up their entire
state support programs
because
the annual budget for fusion research is in
over a billion in the USA, they are
also very heavily involved in all these issues of
public-private partnerships and
milestone-based funding programs
and so on, so
with something like that, yes, definitely,
china is also doing a lot, we just see
a lot less, there’s
only that on paper  a private
company, but we also know that they are
currently building a laser system
outside of Shanghai for 4 billion, which
is also for laser fusion, so China
is also doing a lot there, the USA is
clearly public, but of course we
see a lot more and
Germany clearly has to be careful here
that we don't lose touch,
so we're totally happy that we're now
getting the first public support through the financing from A Innovation, but in the
end no, that's such a construct that
this agency for leap
innovation into a wholly owned
subsidiary  invested by the federal government and
this subsidiary of the federal government then
developed laserfusion, i.e. the laser technology for us, so they are a very
strange construct but there is at least
one possibility to start again now,
his support
does not have any shares in us
because now it also flows in here from my control unit
because I  at the IP
and not there,
so at least not via a
director's stake in us,
but in the past
I think during the corona crisis
the state also got involved directly in the
production of the various vaccines,
so the state could also want to do something
well, you have to say that we
jumped with the agency now. Innovation
is a very fresh development
from March of this year,
but it's really important for us and
we've been working on it for two years now,
because of
course it's also for  private investors it
's a really important signal to see
okay it's a technology that's also
wanted and supported by the state
because otherwise of course as a
private investor I wouldn't say
I'll give you the 200
million
to build the demonstration plant here now if I  I do
n't know anymore whether the state does that
at all
because that would be the normal way that
if I want to get involved in something right
now it's
about these offers but I don't know
how well you know the agency
but otherwise not  take the idea that
this American concept can
also be brought here to Germany and
I think all in all what is that is just
such a state concept where I can
jump, so where I have a pot where
I can invest a jump in innovations
and that  So try
a very successful one in the USA and they are
now trying to do it in Germany via the agency
for jump innovation
and I think they were
a bit tacked on at the beginning
when they were founded
because they were at the beginning  didn't
have that much budget either, and so on, but
now they're gradually being given a bigger
budget, and now they're also investing in
laser fusion infrastructure,
so I'm
very happy that there's something like this in
Germany now, okay,
best case, um, of course, it depends  it also depends on
how many resources we get, so
with more money, more people, you can
do everything faster, so that
's ten years' worth of work
only works if we do
physical validation and
technology development in parallel and if
I use more money for more resources,
now faster  okay
you're left behind by the American film
that's been there for five years
and then it's already spreading in Germany
before you can even
happen it can happen for you but
the good thing is a bit further the
technology we're
pursuing no other pursues  in the world so
from which he there we are really unique
with exactly that has so I
said yes there are a total of these 40
private companies, some
doing magnet fusion others
doing laser fusion everyone does a
bit of a different approach
like I do the fusion  really
technically implement and with the approach
we are pursuing because we are
unique and it can also be patented with it
and exactly or you can
patent the physics process per se but
you can patent the technology behind it
that keeps your
investors in line because I think it
would be
crazier otherwise  crap here and knowing
that you might be the Americans starting in 5
years yes five years
time to make the market here too on
the one hand yes on the other hand
I always say that's how it is so it's not a
winner takes it  Omnipotence because
power is infinitely large and
if several fusion companies should be successful in the end, there
will
certainly be room for two or three
fusion companies, maybe
similar to the vaccines back then,
there were a few
at the same time, yes, and that means one  During
the day the
trade tax, which was then paid on Sunday in
Mainz, could somehow say that
my age is one of the richest cities in the
country, so where are you going to sit
oh God,
eat there or
recruit or have someone or
something
okay, so watch
them closely  next few years the unicorn
lists from Germany when I
scan and see where is Marvel now when
is the time and when is
Marvel really really going to start in
a few years old but I
hope it will
definitely work out thanks to you  bye